and i'm going to have you
today's topic
gonzalez is a 30 year old restaurant
host is from new york city she was
raised in puerto rico that feels very
much like some kind of maori or some
kind of
i don't know the field is really
this moment yeah i know it's moving the
truth but i'm like i had
that that era was very they all filmed
their shows they offered their
shows i told you everything that was
going to happen
and they would do it every time before
every commercial break so you know i was
going to end it coming back is she going
to be the one
we're back from the
advertisement is she the one yeah go
they would kill the suspense sometimes
because sometimes like you'd be out
watching to who to win a millionaire who
wants to be a millionaire right and
you'd be on a question like four and
they go to commercial break but like
wait till you find out how he answers at
two hundred thousand dollars i'm like oh
so oh so he's going to get over here
she has been in a relationship with her
boyfriend for two years
she was asked over 50 questions by a
polygraph examiner 21 have been chosen
for tonight you know what she looked
like
she looked like a mix between britney
spears and stifler's mom
stifler from american pie oh i never
watched american pie it's all good never
mind y'all know you guys watching those
are no no find out who's here with you
tonight i'm derek lissette's boyfriend
i'm alejandra this is mother
shout out to the mall
shout out to them all i'm alejandra
yoshi lisa's mother she looks like if a
fight broke out she pulled the chunkler
yeah yeah you're right yo real quick
find out who's here with you tonight i'm
derek lissette's boyfriend he looks like
the kind of boyfriend who's big and tall
for no reason yeah you know what i mean
like if the girls are getting slapped
you'd be like whoa whoa buddy
oh
buddy
i think we're going a little bit too far
that was
unnecessary dude yeah do your breast
implants make you feel more powerful you
have to put this [ __ ] in context
okay
breast implant back then was not what it
is now no you have to put that [ __ ] in
context the first breast template and it
was like teeny bits you know you would
go from a b
to a b plus and it was like whoa
you really it was a big big thing you
know i mean we didn't know that much and
it was a big thing breast implants was a
big thing so that's a reason for that to
answer that question because now people
would be like
yeah next question
see back in the day breast implants were
on the secret menu of mcdonald's yes now
it's just like getting ketchup with your
fries you gotta they're just gonna give
it to you in the bag everybody got it
yeah it's just like lip exactly and
stuff like that that was very that was
reserved for the young and the rich and
famous yeah yeah yeah the bbl's they
weren't even part of the secret menu now
bbl's are about to graduate yeah and
brazil they've already graduated no it
was it was it was a big talk when
celebrities had them yes and when normal
everybody wanted to know yeah is it real
did she get a t are her breasts real
yeah to be whole articles yeah yeah
you'll be standing out loud in the
grocery store and all of a sudden you're
like assaulted by
what's her name the the paris
paris girl i can't remember her name
persultan yeah
that was the time when being super flat
was like
the
hip bone so it was right above the
crotch
you know all that error it's gonna be my
you know all that [ __ ] yeah all the
christina aguilera grunts
good times that was a good error you
know what's good about that era
we're never going to finish that video
what's good about that era it was like
we was about that ass but it wasn't
mainstream
no no it was still yeah yeah remember
video vixen yeah they were like these
girls were getting all these videos and
people see these well like people were
about to hip-hop yeah
but it wasn't mainstream to have a fat
ass at the time no you know and now it's
like i see a pretty bomb and everyone
else is looking i'm like i remember the
old days when it was special it was just
you you know when i was 10
everybody was looking at the big boob
and then you was like yo i see you my
teacher got a fat ass and i like it and
nobody else in class is appreciating me
yeah you know yeah yeah well i was going
in like in uh in uh
in in high school i was going in a
multi-ethnic we like fat asses so from a
young age i always knew i was a booty
warrior started young all right i got
something for ties
ton of ties
tonight
me personally when i see a girl with
like a nice booty i'm always like
i like you and i want you
and i'm gonna have you
we
i
know it does bro and that's disturbing
lisa johnson
booty warrior yeah
boogie
having some booty was more important
than having water
that was that not for real though so you
did the two versions
you did the real version that was the
boondocks version yeah yeah yeah don't
worry i researched please
johnson we met felice johnson
a long time inmate who practices a very
different kind of homosexuality
but we have sexual desires right so you
got a bunch of mans locked up in one
place
all of them get [ __ ]
all of them's haunted all of them got
sexual desires so what are they going to
do
you won't let them have a woman
they don't have each other
gonna have to give us some booty and it
just ain't simple
in this prison booty
booty was uh
more important than food
booty a man's butt
it was more appropriate
it was more booty
having some booty
[Music]
was more important than drinking water
johnson went on to tell our crew how he
used to satisfy his sexual desires
especially during the 1970s and 80s when
he was most active in prison security
was more lacks
when i see one
and he looks good to me
when i go see him i say you come here
as i'm telling you what
uh i like you and i want you to
and uh
we can do it the easy way out of the
hallway
so the choice is yours right
and it was always yes
johnson also had a warning for the new
generation of inmates they might be
asking for trouble from old timers you
know they got this thing where they
saved their parents
past a book
it's a style they call it some sort of a
gangster style you know it's sexy to us
right
and see what they were preparing for
this right so
you said your fans in her man somebody
be up in your butt you know and it's
just that so i've got no shame in my
game
this is nothing that i'm ashamed to
admit i am what i am
but i'm a while you're too you know so
let that be known i'm aware
not for real though
they got this new gangster style where
they sag and they bust hanging out their
parents i like that
what's his name gang's delicious
[Music]
if you haven't watched booty warrior
fleece you know what though boondocks
can't come back they can't come back it
won't know why because people are not
ready
the minute because riley be saying [ __ ]
too much
no it's because you know i think when it
leaves on such a good note yeah it's
hard to come back from that and build on
that legacy and make something new so
for a lot of artists sometimes they're
like just walking yeah the expectations
are gonna be too much yeah yeah but just
for the record
you were you still a [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i'm not mad at that
do your breast implants make you feel
more powerful
[Music]
boy we're right out of the box aren't we
yeah
i would have never known had it not been
written on this car
they look natural don't they
they really don't there's a look to fake
titties that is so obvious to me when
you're looking at it
well
here's the only time where girls ever
been able to
quasi-food me and it's when women
already have large cheese and they get a
small augmentation then it can be a
little bit because it just kind of lifts
it a little bit but you know once you've
looked at enough titties you kind of
just understand that there's a look to
them that's just unnatural you
understand the gravity of things yay
you understand the mathematics it's like
titties are not supposed to be like that
you understand the supreme mathematics
of titties every now and then though
every now and then i'll encounter twos
that are so nice i'm like these should
be fake
yeah it's like arm leg legs on the head
titties aside yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah
flashbacks
flashbacks when i say perfect perfect
i haven't i've only looked at your eyes
since it started i have no
i don't know what to talk about
yes they do
that answer is
true
three
[Music]
have you deliberately manipulated your
mother into thinking you were a virgin
she sounds latina so yes carry on
yes
did you up until this moment that did
you think that she was a virgin oh yes
yes listen mom
mom
and she didn't go yes she didn't oh yes
yes yes
he's very different so there's two
things here is betty is very
disappointed that you're not married and
you're having sex
there's two possibilities here one she
didn't understand the question she just
says yes to any foreigner
because i've definitely seen that okay
man do you want to get deported oh yes
yes yes love america yes
but i don't think she's to that point or
listen
some parents are just not ready to see
the truth
you think your daughter got a tit job
but anybody using her new fake titties
no they're brand new
look i'm not even mad don't be a version
of them but some parents i don't feel
bad when they're deluded into believing
whatever it is you know
but it said also that she manipulated
her mom so that's also interesting
but also how naive do you have to be i'm
naive you gotta be because you know what
the thing about immigrant parents is
they're very on top of a lot of things
in terms of suspicions when it comes to
certain things yeah and now other things
they just
decide to do see no evil here no evil
my daughter is a virgin
you'd be [ __ ] in the next room my
daughter's a virgin
they're watching netflix it's tv
she's a virgin
stop wrestling in the other room you
guys are crazy
get me out of this one
question six
would you be happy to look like your
mother when you're her age
[Music]
okay i'm gonna tell you this i'm gonna
tell you this i'm gonna tell you this
all right i don't know what it is i
don't know what it is about women in a
certain age they just want to cut their
hair they have this little bob thing
less maintenance less whatever i don't
know what it is but they just cut it in
this little shroom thing
it's a shroom thing
it's just a new thing
and you know when you're used to
something normal
and you're just not liking the way the
ship is going you just need to sometimes
[ __ ] pull on that steering wheel and
go a different direction yeah you need
to [ __ ] sung the ship
you know sink it sync it up it's not
just going how many times have you seen
a girl with long hair cut that [ __ ]
short and it looked terrible yeah
yeah they sink it yeah they still
thinking
it's just sometimes you need you need to
change your paper man i mean this is a
tough question yeah yeah
there's no question this is just trying
to hurt miss chunkler right here yeah
yeah
no no you would not be happy to look
like your mother when you're her age
that answer is
true
[Music]
congratulations you just won 10
dollars yeah good for you
alejandro did you hear that answer yes i
did and how do you feel
[Music]
she's always telling me to do exercise
so i don't look like her
maybe but
maybe not necessarily to see that oh you
just put it she just put it out there
yeah but
there's just some moments where i'm like
i could i don't know if i could what
about you guys watching at home because
you guys
could you guys do that
if you're having the same reaction as me
and you're saying no
leave a like and a comment below like i
wouldn't like to look like my mom
at her age
because i'm not a woman but my dad my
god dude
hey look here he's gonna find himself
you see my dad oh he's not chilling
my dad got swagged yeah yeah
i never seen someone chill like that but
like i want to be on a park bench
looking like that you know what i'm
saying just chilling
i remember when we did the first cookout
and then
you thought about that after this like
yo
if i could chill like your dad i would
your dad's got the opposite energy to
you you're a fire cracker right you're
much more like your mom yeah my energy
is my mom but but more and more the
older i grow the more i'm like i
resemble my dad so i tend to call more i
was worse back like 10 years ago yeah i
was more extreme riots yeah yeah swing
right
swing riot
you don't get it
question 10
have you ever been physically violent
with a boyfriend
yes
you know what's crazy what because i
don't think they could ask that question
to a man on the show have you ever been
violent with your girlfriends in the
past no of course not no no because that
path like this
no
no no no it's not crazy it's just it's
what it is so yeah but if you think
about the question it is crazy but it's
normal by the time she lives yes but
even now
i think now it will pass yeah i've been
i'm you know much less so today much
less so but still pass yeah i agree
question 12
do you think your boyfriend derek has
ever been unfaithful to you
while away on a business trip
yes yes
true
[Music]
[Applause]
that's number 12 congratulations doing
well
derek she basically believes that you
have cheated on her while out of town
she didn't say right you have cheated
she says she believes that you have been
unfaithful while on a business trip what
do you say to that
false it's false that answer is false
has there been any reason that she would
believe that you would have been
unfaithful
no no answer no answer
why did you
look at her
what's going on
yeah that means she got proof
she got received she got receipts she
knows she got received she's gonna shut
the [ __ ] up about it but we'll know
later on tonight
on the show
once again i know the truth you know the
truth yes
but if he does it again it's over
he's not gonna be asked by
no
that nigga's
guilty do not collect 200 dollars
go straight to jail [ __ ]
oh wow guilty oh wow
exactly yeah yeah you know throw the
book at him
all right mr chauvin you going to jail
oh wow
question 13 is not going to be asked by
me it's going to be asked by a special
guest do you want to hear it
all right let's bring out our special
guest with question 13 right now our
special guest right here can you tell
everybody who this is
my first boyfriend david
david said how are you i always like to
see the faces
of the new boyfriend when the x comes in
the picture yeah
you're not so cocky now
you feel like a [ __ ]
cause you see your competition cause you
been cheating on that trick let's go ow
where's your
chin now
come on
where's your chin now not so high
where's your chin now baby i just love
that
right david question 13
have you ever regretted breaking up with
me stop stop stop stop stop cause you
know i've got uh
a fortune 500 company
i've got three cars i've got a dog well
it used to be your dog but we split up
and i gave it to you so i took it back
uh you know you know those titties
you're enjoying you're welcome you're
welcome
uh i'm more you there's a new surgery in
town called bbl's
you already know you want kids i want
kids he doesn't want kids what you're
gonna do huh
so here's the questions to you
yes
bear
where's your chin now baby
turn
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you don't know
if you guys don't understand why he's so
excited back in the 2000s being on tv
was a big deal oh yeah everybody was
watching yeah yeah everyone had it like
dvr to record it everyone was ready for
it if you were you announced to your
friends you gonna be on tv everyone was
tuning in and i was like you know
and you know he probably saw that big
boy right say oh he big and strong but
i occupy your memory
all them broad shoulders but [ __ ]
there's not enough space for you in this
memory
[Laughter]
for free
hey baby you want to play some dungeons
and dragons later she chose me
pokemon i don't know
it was a different time yeah yeah it
gives a lot of context yeah pikachu i
see you that's definitely yeah yeah he's
looking he's not looking at the camera
no no he's looking at his people at home
he's like hey you see that [ __ ]
mom she challenged me
that answer is
true
[Music]
well congratulations that's your 13th
suitable answer how long did you two go
out uh we went out for two years but we
had you know a very special thing
he was a great man
did you know about david i knew that he
was her ex of course yeah yes i did did
that make you uncomfortable at all a
little bit yeah sure question 15
is your former boyfriend david
a better lover
than derek
and he looks like he eats boom boom too
batman right here right here batman
batman right here
what's up
yeah but he cheated on her she stayed
with him so that means like who he got
yeah yeah i know cheaters got the best
dick
that's sex are the best dick you think
yeah yeah that's why the ladies always
stay with them
that's interesting yeah yeah it's like
at the end of the day
somebody is willing to engage in invalid
infidelity is probably willing to engage
a lot more other behaviors
unscrupulous characters do unscrupulous
things
question 16.
no no no let's go back we don't know the
answer to that one our answer is no oh
yeah
have you ever had sexual relations with
someone
in an effort to further your career
your answer no
[Music]
that answer is
false
there's people whistling imagine
there's people whistling
go digger
let's go let's go digger that what you
say go go digger no
go let's go diggers yeah bring it home
diggers hey man yeah go diggers what a
question to just lose all your money
yeah
yeah but again is it at that time
like that would [ __ ] up your chances to
have any kind of work what um because
admitting to the fact that she is that
to get ahead yeah to get ahead anyways
yeah
one more truth is great for that
huh well this show is great for that
yeah
because you know you know what's
interesting about the show it's like
maybe subconscious maybe consciously she
doesn't believe she did but
subconsciously there's a part of hers
that's like remember that one time yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah you could
have conflicting yeah answers
sometimes not even a conscious lie
but you know
it's not even about true
it's if you believe yourself or not hmm
it's really that do you believe do you
believe what you just said you have a
doubt if you have a doubt
[Music]
like that
your mom your boyfriend
and uh give your ex an ego boost for
zero dollars so congratulations
the sound effects nasty
not like legitimately disgusting i know
but uh anyways
that's it for today's video if you guys
enjoyed it leave a comment below boom if
you want to see us do more of these
leave a comment let us know you want
more moments of truths all right there's
some crazy episodes out there that you
guys have never seen that you may never
find because it's really well hidden if
you guys want us to show it to you we
can okay also
if you guys enjoyed this little
discussion about what it was like in the
90s and 2000s some of the differences
culturally in regards to plastic surgery
that's going to be a bonus clip that's
going to be up on the patreons
[Music]
[Applause]
buddy
[Music]